it's some of both we try to construct
theoretical models that represent
real-life situations but like any model
they simplify the situation and we try
to derive consequences of our
assumptions it's a mathematical model so
we deduce what our assumptions indicate
we prove theorems as they're called but
we also ask about the applicability of
these theorems these consequences in
real-life cases so one gets one's an
inspiration usually from observing what
happens in the real world and those are
the kinds of things I teach but I try to
make them more coherent understand them
at a more scientific idle by
constructing a model a model might be
something like that if you can array the
candidates on a left-right
continuum yuo vote for the candidate
closest to you now that is off is
complicated often by the fact that the
person closest to you the candidate
might be somebody who has little chance
of winning so you might want to alter
your choice to vote for a more viable
second choice a third choice a good
example of this was a 2000 u.s.
presidential election in which Ralph
Nader was a third party candidate he
ended up getting less than 3% of the
popular vote he won no state so he got
no electoral votes and native supporters
generally on the far left were torn
should they vote for Nader who had no
chance of winning or should they switch
to a second choice for many of the NATO
supporters that would have been a
Democrat Al Gore and in some cases they
were torn and one consequence of being
torn is you don't vote at all you can't
make up your mind but some swish and
some did not switch of course the major
consequence was that enough
stuck with Nader so that he by all
accounts affected the election outcome
in particular in Florida Bush in the end
got about five hundred one beat gore by
about five hundred votes but there were
ninety seven thousand native supporters
in Florida and if most of them had gone
for Gore as a second choice then Gore
would have won by tens of thousands of
votes instead of losing by about five
hundred that would have changed the
outcome in the country as a whole and we
would have had a different president so
that's a good example of a so-called
spoiler somebody who can't win who
changes the election outcome so those
are the kinds of situations that we
study and I think these models are very
helpful in understanding them
well I think what I just suggested about
the 2000 election is the example if
you'll feel that the consequences of
electing borscht let's say you're a
Democrat filed after leaning are
sufficiently problematic then and you
were native supporter then you might
well switch that would be the rational
choice but if you think neither
candidate was very good as Nader argued
they were both kind of the same cloth
then you would not switch and your vote
would be more a protest vote so
rationality may move voters in different
directions depending on their
preferences their goals you want to just
protest I do want to affect the election
outcome and try to affect the election
outcome